[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález la violencia
contra las mujeres y las niñas es una de
las violaciones de los derechos humanos
predominante y más extendida a lo largo
y ancho del planeta los hechos de
violencia se dan tanto en el ámbito
doméstico también en la mayoría de los
casos por parte de familiares o de
parejas pero también tienen lugar en el
ámbito público y tienen un rango muy
amplio de formas de manifestarse que
pueden ir desde la agresión verbal
física sexual psicológica y hasta
económica estos hechos de violencia y de
agresión no identifican ni edad ni raza
país continente a nivel socioeconómico
pero si hay una región en la que la
violencia contra la mujer sigue
presentando cifras alarmantes y es
nuestra región américa latina en donde
una o cada dos horas mejor una mujer es
asesinada solo por el hecho de ser mujer
es el segundo continente con más
feminicidios en el mundo después del
continente africano
recordemos que el feminicidio es tal vez
una de las formas de violencia contra
las mujeres más en nuestro planeta
veamos más detalles de cómo está el
panorama en el siguiente informe
preparado por la redacción de france 24
una pandemia en la sombra la violencia
machista se ha agudizado en
latinoamérica desde la llegada del
hobbit 19 según la onu 30% de las
mujeres del continente han sufrido de
violencia física o sexual por parte de
sus parejas y 11 por ciento a manos de
otras personas ha aumentado muchísimo a
las llamadas denuncias han aumentado las
agresiones
y digamos a través
whatsapp a través d
e instagram de facebook de todos los
medios sociales de comunicación la
comisión económica para américa latina y
el caribe reportó que en el 2020 hubo al
menos cuatro mil diecinueve feminicidios
en américa latina' una cifra que a pesar
de que muestra una disminución del 10 6
por ciento de los casos con respecto a
2019 es dispar entre los países de la
región las tasas más altas de la región
las tienen honduras república dominicana
y el salvador y en bolivia durante los
71 días que duró la cuarentena se
registraron dos mil 935 denuncias de
violencia sexual y 113 feminicidios
durante los confinamientos estrictos y
mixtos yo diría que la violencia contra
las mujeres en américa latina y en
bolivia tiene dimensiones endémicas el
informe muestra que los feminicidios se
dan en mayor cantidad en las mujeres de
entre 30 y 44 años pero alertaron de la
situación de las niñas menores de 15
años al menos 40 fueron víctimas del
[Aplausos]
bueno pues para analizar este tema hemos
invitado a cecilia alemani ella es
directora regional adjunta de onu
mujeres para las américas y el caribe ya
se encuentra en la ciudad de montevideo
en uruguay también está con nosotros
'china team' bin y ella representante de
la ope s o ms en colombia y aquí en el
estudio de france 24 nos acompaña elena
gómez ella es abogada de derechos
humanos y justicia social ella se parte
también de la red jurídica feminista en
este país ustedes nuestros televidentes
también pueden participar en este debate
con todos sus comentarios y sus
preguntas los pueden dejar a través de
nuestras redes sociales no se encuentran
en facebook en instagram y en twitter
estamos como france24 y un bajo ese
arroba sant y luego que es mi cuenta
personal les recuerdo que nuestra
etiqueta es numeral el debate efe 24
esperamos todos sus comentarios y sus
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
pues comienzo entonces con cecilia en la
ciudad de montevideo en la capital
uruguaya
conociendo primero un panorama general
para que luego vayamos adentrándonos en
diferentes temas que tengo para esta
agenda y quiero conocer entonces cecilia
el balance que usted hace de esta lucha
los logros alcanzados que se puede
destacar y que hace falta
bueno el reporte que ustedes acaban de
presentar muestra muy bien los desafíos
de la región américa latina ha avanzado
en el desarrollo de
nuevas leyes integrales de violencia que
tipifican delitos como el feminicidio
que es uno de los mayores problemas
ha agotado a las mujeres a través de
toda la región y por eso salen en masa a
las calles a decir ni una menos ni una
más ya ella que es una de las consignas
de la campaña de este año desde naciones
unidas y unas mujeres de que el fin de
la violencia es ahora no podemos esperar
al 2030
o más allá que son otras de las metas de
largo plazo ahora bien todavía tenemos
países en el caribe que no han
tipificado el feminicidio y en los demás
países cuando tenemos normas avanzadas
no necesariamente tenemos los sistemas
de justicia adecuados ni los sistemas de
prevención ni se priorizan los
presupuestos nacionales
la respuesta la reparación o la
protección de las víctimas o sea las
leyes han mejorado la sociedad también
porque hablamos de estas cosas como hoy
con ustedes esta noche
vamos a analizar algunos de esos temas
cecilia gina quiero conocer su opinión
también cuál es el balance que usted
hace tanto de la región como de su país
en el que usted se encuentra colombia
y sí gracias gracias por tener este
espacio en que podamos intercambiar con
las diferentes personas que están
conectadas y poner muy claro que es un
problema muy serio y desde salud
consideramos como un problema de salud
pública porque tiene consecuencias a
corto mediano plazo que afectan a las
mujeres y no solamente a las mujeres
sino también a sus familias a las
comunidades ya toda la sociedad y muy
claramente se ha mencionado de que en
las américas se afecta una de cada tres
mujeres en las cuales se está vulnerando
sus derechos humanos y como les decía
consideramos que es un problema
importante de salud pública en colombia
hay cifras del instituto nacional de la
salud que indican que en el año 2021 se
han reportado 74 mil 528 casos
sospechosos de violencia de género de
los cuales el 50 por ciento has
identificado como violencia física y más
del 20 por ciento como violencia sexual
las mujeres resultan ser las más
afectadas siendo el 80% de estas
víctimas del crimen el estudio de france
24 para terminar esta ronda de panorama
general y elena gómez está con nosotros
aquí en el estudio elena su balance
general de esta situación de la lucha de
los avances que ha habido y de lo que
falta por hacer bueno el balance general
es muy complicado porque como bien han
dicho mis compañeras una de cada tres
mujeres es víctima pero solamente una de
cada diez mujeres víctimas de violencia
finalmente acuda de las autoridades
entonces cuando miramos las cifras estas
de todas formas están infladas y no sólo
eso sino las mujeres están saliendo a
las calles las mujeres están
manifestando nos estamos manifestando
justamente porque hemos encontrado que
la institucionalidad no ha estado
respondiendo y porque después de la
pandemia el sufrimiento los casos de
violencia las cifras subieron en un en
cifras ridículas es decir en violencia
física aproximadamente aumentó en un 31%
en los casos de violencia física
económica en un 97 por ciento entonces
el panorama general es preocupante y la
institucionalidad todavía no daba una
respuesta necesaria
todas las violencias que se están
presentando vamos a mirar este tema de
la institucionalidad y la parte judicial
quiero comenzar mirando las cifras de
américa latina ya lo hemos mencionado
somos el continente con después de
áfrica con mayor cantidad de casos
seguimos teniendo serios problemas en
torno a la lucha contra la violencia de
género casos críticos honduras república
dominicana y el salvador miremos en
perspectiva
cecilia en la ciudad de montevideo que
es lo que caracteriza a estos países
tienen algo en común para que sigan
registrando estas cifras tan altas y
como están organizadas allí las leyes y
que tanta protección tienen las mujeres
porque si estos países empiezan a
comparar con otros de la región pues se
están muy atrasados en la legislación y
en muchos otros aspectos
sí bueno el ejercicio de los derechos en
un sentido amplio tiene tiene que ver
con el aumento de la violencia y también
el hecho de que las mujeres tengan o no
ingresos propios o medios de vida en
algunos países estamos hablando que como
por ejemplo en guatemala uno de los
países vecinos 60% de las mujeres no
tienen ingresos propios y después que
estamos en países donde hay un marco de
violencia instalado que esto genera un
círculo que exacerba el hecho de que las
instituciones no asuman ese rol de
protección de los derechos en un sentido
amplio o no tengan las capacidades para
frenar esta pandemia en la sombra que
son los feminicidios es un factor
importante en la capacidad institucional
la capacidad de las instituciones
democráticas de las organizaciones de
mujeres y feministas de poder hacer su
trabajo de alguna manera ampliando el
espacio cívico dando herramientas
también a los distintos grupos de
mujeres y comunidades de mujeres
para poder avanzar el avance de las
mujeres rurales y de las mujeres
indígenas es todo un desafío y en
particular y con esto termino en
república dominicana un carácter
importante tiene que ver con la reciente
modificación de la norma pero que hasta
hace muy poco el matrimonio infantil
estaba habilitado y esto lamentablemente
tiene mucha relación con la violencia
china en la ciudad de bogotá su
perspectiva desde el lado de la salud en
cuanto a estos tres países honduras el
salvador y república dominicana hay
avances en las políticas tal vez para
impulsar a nivel gobiernos se debe
ejercer más presión como lo vio usted
desde el sector salud lo que estamos
buscando sobre todo es fortalecer la
capacidad de respuesta de los servicios
de prevención y de atención y como digo
especialmente en el sector salud también
en lo que es la generación de evidencias
científicas que busquen advertir esta
situación de violencia contra las
mujeres acá en colombia y también sé de
otros países de la región y poder
aportar al cierre de esas brechas y a su
erradicación así también se está
trabajando en la elaboración y revisión
de políticas y planes nacionales para
poder fortalecer esa atención integral
esa respuesta integral y que también
debe partir mucho no solamente en el
hecho de acciones de prevención y
atención sino también poder trabajar en
acciones para la transformación de los
estereotipos de género
masculinidades no hemo génicas en los
niños adolescentes en los hombres y en
el empoderamiento de toma de decisiones
y la autonomía con las niñas
adolescentes y mujeres
en el caso del salvador llama mucho la
atención porque tal parece que este país
sigue sin tener unas políticas reales
para abordar los temas de violencia de
la mujer según mis notas tengo acá que
este país centroamericano cerró el
tercer trimestre del 2021 del 2021 con
un aumento del 31 25 por ciento en los
casos aquí como hacer revertir estas
cifras presión ciudadana presión desde
los colectivos de las mujeres desde los
grupos feministas
que la sociedad exija o tratar desde las
organizaciones internacionales de
ejercer un poco de presión al gobierno
de turno pues es complejo pero hemos
visto que las movilizaciones sociales
que el activismo real y la incidencia
política realmente ejercen cambio lo
vemos nomás con todo el tema de la
oleada verde la despenalización del
aborto esto empieza a mover masas y
empieza a mover países entonces algo que
inicialmente sucedió en argentina
después se movió a méxico ahora se está
moviendo en colombia y así funcionan
estas cosas entonces todo el tema de la
violencia que sin duda es muy fuerte y
américa latina como bien ya mencionadas
donde las altas están las de las tasas
están más desfasados la movilización
social y la presión siempre terminan por
ejercer algún tipo de digamos que
dominio en por lo menos las agendas
políticas entonces saber qué es lo que
se está pidiendo qué es lo que se
necesita también porque como mencionaba
ahora claro las cifras nos dan unos
números pero realmente cuántas mujeres
están siendo víctimas eso es importante
y eso solamente lo muestra la
movilización y el activismo porque las
mujeres víctimas son quienes están
diciendo escúchenme
y no sólo escúchenme si no atiendan me
tengo unas necesidades
cecilia en la ciudad de montevideo en
uruguay le pregunto hay algún país
destacado en la región que haya tomado
un liderazgo en cuanto a la parte de
políticas que realmente se están
poniendo en marcha que realmente se esté
dando una protección a las mujeres y que
sea el ejemplo para la región y que
podamos seguir por la buena experiencia
que han tenido
bueno es difícil dar ejemplos en este
sentido porque todos los países tienen
luces y sombras en algún caso podemos
decir que hay una ley ejemplar como por
ejemplo la ley micaela contra la
violencia en argentina sin embargo
siguen matando una mujer cada 35 horas
hay un psoe minicipio cada 35 horas en
argentina a pesar de tener una ley
ejemplar
entonces es difícil poner ejemplos hay
países que tienen un compromiso muy
fuerte por erradicar la violencia como
puede ser costa rica sin embargo cuando
miramos la cifra de feminicidios del 19
al 20 aumentaron
entonces es un fenómeno muy complejo
aquí lo fundamental es asegurar primero
los marcos legales integrales que las
organizaciones de mujeres y feministas
puedan tener acceso a financiamiento
espacios para la influencia y la
prevención tanto que tocaba recién del
salvador es uno de los preocupantes en
este sentido porque las propias
organizaciones que trabajan por la
erradicación de la violencia tienen
dificultades para poder seguir avanzando
esta agenda y promoviendo estos cambios
en diálogo con el gobierno y los demás
actores jim en la ciudad de bogotá la
misma pregunta desde su perspectiva de
algún país que pueda tener alguna
política o algún ejemplo destacado en la
región que usted pueda tener en cuenta
para poner aquí sobre la mesa
bien bien lo decía cecilia no hay
aspectos positivos y negativos en
términos de lo que se viene haciendo
pero yo creo que acá el alerta es que
todavía somos una región en que este es
un problema
muy fuerte y que sobre todo está muy
relacionado también a problemas muy
estructurales como es las desigualdades
profundas la pobreza multidimensional
los bajos niveles de educación que tiene
la población en nuestros países de la
región y las américas entonces también
es poder ver como desde las políticas y
de las inversiones del gobierno también
se atiende estos problemas estructurales
elena en el estudio france24 le cambió
la pregunta ya hemos hablado del marco
jurídico y de el avance que pueden tener
algunos de los países es difícil
encontrar un ejemplo digamos consagrado
se pueden tomar piezas de cada uno de
los países y armar un muy buen caso
de éxito pero entonces qué hay del
imaginario que hay de la cultura cada
uno de los países si bien cambian las
leyes la mentalidad de la sociedad sigue
siendo todavía un poco atrasada en
cuanto a la perspectiva que hay que
tener sobre este tema
ha habido avance en eso en la cultura en
el imaginario sobre todo en las zonas
rurales apartadas donde el maltrato es
parte normal de la del día a día
prácticamente en las familias en algunas
regiones como lo ve usted pues es un
problema como ya he mencionado
estructurar entonces esto no es algo que
vaya a cambiar del día de la mañana por
más que la institucionalidad haga cosas
hagan cambios pues realmente esto es
algo que está mucho más en la raíz lo
que vemos en la ruralidad es pues el
acceso a la información es mucho más
precario por ejemplo desde el movimiento
social que yo hago parte desde digamos
que la movilización lo que más nos
llegan son casos justamente de mujeres
rurales que no tienen acceso a la
información entonces desde ahí
encontramos la primera barrera claro
entonces no es solamente un tema de
bueno esto cuando ir a cambiar las
personas de todas formas tenemos digamos
que estos arraigos estructurales y
hegemónicos que hacemos con eso la
información hay un acceso a la
información que es precario las mujeres
no saben cuáles son sus derechos en
nuestras ocasiones y si bien esas
mayorías los derechos no sabes cómo
exigir ni que puedas exigir entonces ahí
acuden a organizaciones sociales oa
movimientos que como mencionaba a
cecilia pues la financiación es precaria
también pero es un poco la herramienta
cecilia ya nivel del estado también como
lo ve usted hay políticas para este
cambio a nivel cultural en más
información a través de los medios de
comunicación qué papel tienen que jugar
los medios de comunicación allí para
difundir este cambio cultural este
cambio de mentalidad de los ciudadanos
frente a este tema
totalmente es un cambio de mentalidad y
un cambio cultural en el que creo que ya
estamos embarcados como sociedades
latinoamericana porque realmente podemos
hablar de forma mucho más clara estos
problemas y ustedes de los medios tienen
un rol muy importante de jugar el
primero es no reproducir estereotipos de
género tradicionales que llevan a
a la violencia como una forma natural
del relacionamiento entre las personas y
este es un tema sensible porque primero
hay que comprender esos esos
estereotipos esos hijos de género que
tenemos por el cual por ejemplo desde
muy pequeños asociamos a las mujeres a
una profesión y a los hombres a otro y
esto implica todas las distintas escalas
de realización con las cuales se
construyen los imaginarios colectivos y
sociales el segundo es que la violencia
sexual y la violencia contra las mujeres
está muy instalada en todo el imaginario
colectivo como algo natural entonces se
reproducen los bienes culturales que
consumimos en la publicidad y muchas
veces los propios medios de comunicación
construyen los titulares de las noticias
desde un lugar que es discriminatorio y
que tiende a reproducir esos sesgos y
esa cultura arcaica que tú decías con la
cual estamos tratando de transformar lo
que estamos tratando de llevar a
entonces si hay un rol fundamental que
es promover el cambio de la
transformación para una sociedad que
respete a todas las personas que
respeten a las mujeres y que esas mismas
puedan ejercer estos derechos en
conocimiento de causa pero en su en
conclusión cecilia a esta pregunta ya
estamos embarcados en eso estamos en el
proceso de cambios y luego usted desde
los estados hay un poco más de difusión
sobre estos cambios y tratando de
generar conocimientos sobre estas leyes
estos derechos como reclamar y los
procedimientos eso ya está en marcha
está en marcha en la mayoría de los
países no hicimos todavía tenemos
candidatos que dicen que están en contra
de la igualdad de género candidatos
políticos en acción ahora que está en
marcha si la forma de consolidarse tiene
que ver con la incorporación de el
cambio de los estereotipos de género y
la educación hacia la igualdad de género
en la educación sin la formal y en la
formal el día que tengamos planes
educativos que incorporen dentro de la
educación primaria secundaria y
terciaria y profesional la igualdad de
género como una materia más que es un
derecho constitucional pero ahí
realmente habremos logrado el cambio
pero yo y desde unas mujeres estamos
convencidas que el cambio ha empezado
empezó bueno hace muchas décadas que
empezó y quizás hoy podríamos con todas
las tecnologías que tenemos y la
capacidad de comunicación de los medios
que las personas individualmente
acelerarnos
y gina desde la parte de la salud
también cómo acortar esa inequidad que
hay entre hombres y mujeres en muchos de
los accesos a los servicios eso también
puede ser considerado una forma de
violencia esta inequidad y esta
indiferencia en algunos casos de las
mujeres en esto también entra en temas
como la interrupción del embarazo que es
un tema muy debatido ahora en la región
y donde vemos
extremos
opuestos como el salvador y argentina
donde se ven completamente las dos caras
de la moneda como lo vio usted
si como mencionábamos la violencia
contra mujeres es un problema de salud
pública y que tiene consecuencias a
mediano a largo plazo y también
consecuencias inmediatas y fatales como
bien lo ha mencionado el término de la
muerte muerte de estas de esas mujeres
desde los servicios de salud hay un
esfuerzo para fortalecer
esas capacidades para poder detectar
esos signos en esa mujer que llega o la
niña o la familia que llega a detectar
los signos que pudiera haber un problema
de violencia inter intrafamiliar o
violencia directamente hacia mujeres o
niñas y se viene se viene trabajando en
eso la generación de información de
evidencias que haga más visible esta
problemática también ayuda y el hecho de
poder incidir en políticas y en planes
nacionales que buscan esa atención
integral de las personas que están
haciendo afectadas por la violencia de
género
china continuo con ustedes ya la de la
palabra elena va a hacer la ronda a la
inversa
y el discurso político
minimiza un poco la magnitud de esta
problemática en nuestra región cree
usted que algunos gobiernos algunos
presidentes o mandatarios locales tratan
de hacer ver esto como que es un tema
privado que es un tema al interior de
las familias y que no es un tema que le
corresponde a los gobiernos a los
estados responsabilizarse cómo lo ve
si eso eso es muy serio y se muestra se
muestra muestran los datos que
encontramos que a ahora desde 15 15 a 20
personas o sea casi un 73
77 por ciento indica que deben ser temas
a ser tratados dentro de caso no que la
ropa sucia se lava entró de casa y no
debe ser así
todas estas campañas que decimos basta
de violencia paremos con la violencia
contra las mujeres ya el únete cierto la
iniciativa de united el secretario
general busca que tomemos acciones ya y
que sea visible y que empodere moss
también esas mujeres para que puedan
realmente hablar de esto y ccoo y acudir
a donde puedan tener un apoyo
elena por este lado los gobiernos
minimizan con su discurso político esta
problemática y creo que esto un poco no
sé cómo lo ve usted un poco entrelazado
con la impunidad y el miedo también a
denunciar por parte de las mujeres de
salvemos aquí un poco desde este tema
pues yo diría que respecto a los
gobiernos y en general pasa algo que se
le llamaría por población y es también
el uso y la instrumentalización de las
luchas de género
para ganar votos en muchos casos para
intentar calmar las aguas pero a la hora
de ejercer políticas políticas políticas
de salud pues eso se queda un poquito en
el aire entonces yo creo que en primer
lugar es importante decir eso y es se
está haciendo una instrumentalización
del discurso sin que realmente éste esté
siendo efectivo es decir lo usan pero
realmente no hay cambios muy profundos
al respecto
claro cuando esto sucede vamos a un
segundo escenario y es si las mujeres de
por si tienen miedo de denunciar porque
porque la mayoría de casos viven con sus
agresores porque hay violencia económica
de por medio por muchas razones y además
ven que hay un discurso que realmente no
está surtiendo efecto pues claro los
niveles de denuncia son mucho mayores y
el mensaje que está terminando en las
cortes y en los escenarios judiciales es
pues los jueces tampoco se lo toman muy
en serio porque si desde los gobiernos
no es un tema más allá de la
instrumentalización porque un juez se lo
tomaría en serio claro y qué hay de la
impunidad que es un gran problema en la
justicia en américa latina' no solamente
en este tema sino en la mayoría de casos
por eso tenemos los niveles de
corrupción que tenemos en nuestros
países
que se puede hacer frente a estos casos
en particular donde hay un la vida de un
ser humano de por medio en muchísimo en
la mayoría de los casos pues yo creo que
el problema principal es principal es
que no se está haciendo justicia con un
enfoque interseccional de género
entonces lo primero que es necesario es
para que no haya impunidad o para que la
tasa de impunidad baje muchísimo es
necesario que las personas que están
administrando justicia tengan un enfoque
de género y un enfoque interseccional
que no revictimizar y que además de en
penas que realmente busquen la
reparación entonces lo importante es
pues que realmente haya una educación
para los administradores de justicia con
enfoque de género cecilia que dice usted
al respecto enfoque de género evitar la
revictimización
nos falta dar ese paso todavía como lo
ve usted
si nos falta dicen paso todavía aunque
hay esfuerzo tengo que decir
completamente de acuerdo con los puntos
de gina y arena
desde onu-mujeres con el alto
comisionado derechos humanos justamente
hemos elaborado una guía junto a los
sistemas de justicia que se ha trabajado
muy de cerca apuntó el ecosistema en
ecuador y en uruguay
justamente en este sentido para educar
para una justicia interseccional y con
perspectiva de género a los jueces y a
todo el ecosistema tenemos que hacer
esto en toda américa latina con todas
las contrapartes porque realmente ese es
un desafío y también todas las políticas
públicas el problema de la violencia se
da en la política hace esta impunidad
tiempo colocaste que va más allá de de
la violencia contra las mujeres es un
problema que tenemos que resolver tiene
que ver con la calidad de la democracia
en las evaluaciones rápidas de género
que publicamos hacer el informe global
desde una mujer es uno de los temas y
varios los datos fuertes que se veían
por ejemplo en nuestras colegas en
méxico nos decían que una de cada dos
presidentas municipales había sido leída
durante la campaña entonces tenemos esta
violencia que está pasando a todos los
ámbitos de la sociedad que por supuesto
tiene una manifestación directa y en
particular con los feminicidios
y la violencia sexual cuando se trata de
parejas o exparejas pero que se da
también a nivel institucionalizado y que
se está trasladando a otros ámbitos de
la gmvv ya que tenemos más mujeres en
políticas hay más violencia política así
que ahí tenemos que hacer políticas de
estado ya no solo políticas de gobierno
que nos aseguren que no haya impunidad
que no nos acostumbremos a esta forma de
violencia y que se invierta en el cambio
porque también hay que invertir para las
políticas de resultados no sé si me
quedo con un término que usted menciona
y es calidad de la democracia en
nuestros países que ya también lo
podríamos analizar daría para todo un
programa entero para debatir sobre eso
estos cambios y garantizaré cecilia esta
disminución de la impunidad y este miedo
que tienen las mujeres a denunciar
porque los sistemas jurídicos no son muy
efectivos pasa precisamente por la
igualdad que las mujeres puedan acceder
a los puestos públicos a los cargos en
el gobierno que todavía en nuestros
países sigue siendo una deuda pendiente
no vemos gobiernos como vemos en otros
escenarios mucho más avanzados me viene
a la cabeza el caso de finlandia por
ejemplo o islandia donde los gobiernos
han tenido una representación femenina
alta recientemente
evidentemente todavía estamos muy lejos
de que las mujeres estén representadas
en términos sanitarios en todos los
ámbitos en el económico y en el político
claramente en el social hay mayor
participación es una forma de revertir
esto es generando en normativas para la
paridad en todos los ámbitos en el
ejecutivo en el legislativo y en el
judicial y esto realmente sabemos que es
la manera de avanzar una vez que esa
paridad se instala y la cuota ni la
paridad hacen falta pero es la manera de
generar el cambio cultural con los
incentivos para que así sea ahora bien y
un último punto en política el gran
desafío tiene que ver con el
financiamiento de los partidos políticos
y el acceso aa
qué más de poder y de reproducción de
poder que han sido tradicionalmente
masculinizados así que ahí también hay
impunidad y hay temor de denunciar
diferente a pocos minutos para terminar
el programa voy a comenzar con las
conclusiones comienzo con elena quien el
estudio de france 24 conclusiones de lo
que
queda por delante los retos en qué áreas
hacer énfasis desde su desde su
perspectiva elena deberían de ser los
puntos base a partir de este momento
para fortalecer esta lucha contra la
violencia de género pues en primer lugar
creo que lo que mencionaba cecilia sin
duda es cúspide y es la participación
política las mujeres necesitamos paridad
necesitamos un acceso
a la participación política que
realmente sea equitativo entonces eso en
primer lugar en segundo lugar políticas
públicas políticas públicas que permitan
la minimización de la violencia y en
tercer lugar pues un acceso a la
justicia que no tenga tantas barreras
porque claro las mujeres no somos todas
iguales respecto al acceso a la justicia
que tenemos es decir yo elena no tengo
el mismo acceso a la justicia o las
mismas barreras que tendría una mujer
rural o que tendría una mujer indígena
entonces es muy importante reconocer las
barreras de la justicia y minimizar las
y esto solamente se puede hacer en el
acceso a la justicia entonces estos
serían los tres elementos que yo
considero que son fundamentales y que
hasta que eso no suceda pues no vamos a
ver un cambio digamos que muy coyuntural
si china en la ciudad de bogotá sus
conclusiones su perspectiva que queda
por delante de los retos los puntos que
sean base a partir de este momento para
continuar con esa lucha
claro en el sector salud desde la
organización panamericana de la salud y
organización mundial de la salud pues
seguir trabajando en fortalecer esa
capacidad de la respuesta de los
servicios de prevención y de atención
especialmente como les decía pues en
todo lo que es esa red de servicios de
salud en esa generación de más evidencia
generación de mayor información que haga
más visible esta problemática y que nos
permite identificar las brechas sobre
todo en las diferentes poblaciones
porque sabemos que hay una importancia
en términos de la diferencia de étnica o
de dónde vienen estas mujeres o dónde
están
desarrollándose en el día a día
y tercer yo diría yo por reforzar lo que
es esa revisión de las políticas y
planes nacionales para poder fortalecer
esa respuesta integral a las violencias
de género y una pues prevención atención
información puntos clave que ha
destacado nuestra invitada en la ciudad
de bogotá y terminó las conclusiones
para el cierre cecilia alemania en la
ciudad de montevideo cuáles son sus
conclusiones
adhiero a todas las conclusiones de gina
y elena y agrego básicamente
financiamiento a las organizaciones de
mujeres y feministas financiamiento para
las instituciones públicas que hacen la
prevención y la reparación y las
respuestas a las víctimas los refugios
los servicios de llamadas que se
declaran servicios esenciales todos los
servicios de prevención y respuesta que
se produzcan evidencia estadísticas y
estadísticas de calidad que permita
mejorar esta lectura que estamos
haciendo hoy de la realidad y a la vez
hacer políticas públicas basadas en
evidencia empírica y básicamente que se
combinen las urgencia de corto plazo con
las necesidades de mediano y largo plazo
para que esta transformación
no siga haciendo este está el lamento
que tenemos compartido hoy por todos los
feminicidios que seguimos teniendo pues
accesibilidad y nahia elena muchísimas
gracias panel de primerísimo nivel hoy
aquí en el debate de france 24 les
agradezco por haber estado con nosotros
haber analizado este tema para la
audiencia en américa latina' ustedes
muchas gracias por la sintonía pueden
seguir dejando sus comentarios y
preguntas a través de las redes le
siguen con nuestra programación buenas
noches
[Música]